hi um now I know that you guys are being
investigated as to who funds you who
supports you and you've been major
players in two protests in New York City
one in June and one in September and
they want to know where your money is
coming from but do you they're not
interested in where's a money coming
from and I think it's like 125 million
for this
Mega yeah where do you guys think that
125 million for the mosque is coming
from um well that's the question that's
the question isn't it look our funding
comes from our readers they donate to
the site Atlas shrugs Jihad watch $18
$20 $50 all over the world that's why we
buy these bus campaigns to help the
apostates we bought City by City
otherwise I would have rolled it out
nation wide otherwise I would have
bought 2,000 buses not 20 uh this is De
a deep troubling question to be honest
you we know that for example he received
funds and this was this is all open
source world's economic Forum he
received from from from xnl xnl was
scheduled to build a uh Convention
Center in Kiss Florida and the uh
project was killed it was killed because
nxl is uh Osama Bin Laden's family and
his company and so the people in Florida
they came out against this project and
it was killed I would think that if a
project in kissamee Florida convention
sentor could be killed then certainly a
a 15 16 story Mega moset Ground Zero
ought to be reconsidered as well I mean
you may want you may have other thoughts
it's all conjecture I think they're
having problems with with laundering the
money I think that's what that's why
they they have they have what $118,000
$188,000 in the bank account now and
you're talking of anywhere between $125
and $150 million
um they don't have it now they said I
just want you to know we're not going to
take it from Iran or Hamas just so that
you know you're not allowed to take
money from Iran or Hamas the state
department designated terrorist groups
you cannot take money from them so he's
saying is I'm not going to break the
lore in front of your
face um you have to add
anything well the main thing is is that
it's a question and nobody seems to care
and it's very interesting that you noted
in in terms of uh our own financing
because yeah we get uh $8 $20 $100
donations on the websites and we we get
them from a lot of people because a lot
of people support us and we uh are able
to get spend $8,000 and buy a bus ad
about apostasy and the rights of the
apostates uh the human rights of the
apostates uh that nobody seems to care
about and that's you know that's that's
small change my friend that's not big
money and then there's this $100 million
over here and there's this waiter who
suddenly becomes a multi-millionaire and
nobody seems to know where the money's
coming from and nobody seems to care and
Nancy Pelosi said we have to investigate
the opponents of the mosque and the next
day Politico called me asking about
money uh but he I I he I guarantee you
he did not call the Imam
R and one last thing the waiter who
became a big Mega developer uh two years
later it wasn't even his money he the
Hisham Elan right elenadi thank you
elenadi is The Quiet Partner in all this
and he not once but twice Medicaid for
to the tunea the last time in 2006
$336,000 he defrauded Medicaid I don't
know why uh he didn't go to jail for
that oh yeah and also uh Imam rou I'm I
don't know if you're aware of it is a
slumlord now I didn't say that I'm not
defaming or smearing this is the the
city Union City who's suing him said
he's a slum Lord he has these buildings
and the people are living in Untold Hara
the toilet water and and rats and and
broken doors and no Heating and no
Cooling and by the way he was given $2
million to make repairs to the slums and
still the repairs have not been made and
now he's being sued to where where's
that money and why is the New York Times
all over like they're all over my $18
donations I'm serious they there was an
exchange just before I got here with the
New York Times now the $25 that went to
um Jihad
watch uh nobody's asking these questions
and I think it's deeply troubling that
an Imam a man of the cloth sort of uh
would be would would be a slum Lord
wouldn't you and that he would lie on
his tax return saying that one of their
one of their residences a one-bedroom
apartment in New York City was a
mask and that five over 500 people were
worshiping there why would he do that so
that he could get tax exemp
status you know True Confessions I I did
not come to this talk thinking I would
agree with what you said um and I do
feel rather limited with with what you
just said about filibusters I have no
intention of filibuster but I wonder if
if I have a chance to do anything beyond
ask a question
um I and so I'll try to frame this as a
question given what you just said um do
you think that
that what you are presenting a couple of
questions do you think that what you're
presenting is fostering mutual respect
and understanding
between my ballpark estimates 1.5
billion Christians and 1 billion Muslims
worldwide um and do you think that the
manner in which you're character
characterizing Islam and perhaps by by
virtue of mostly silence you were
characterizing
Christianity
um is is a fair characterization of the
two given historical instances of
slavery and genocide on several sides um
and given globalization impact on
environment and and worldwide
poverty um
and let's yeah those two questions well
first I just want to address your a very
important point and I thank you for
bringing it up mutual respect and mutual
understanding I ask you where is the
reciprocity I think that we're very
respectful I think that frankly that
we're
trading um freedom for peace in which
case you'll get
neither but in the case of the mosque
where's the
reciprocity we are constantly
accommodating this hypers sensitivity in
the Muslim world and mutual respect and
mutual understanding is a two-way street
and and I don't see it I don't see it I
do not mean to I I I don't believe we're
responsible for this Discord I don't
believe we're responsible for this
disharmony I lay this solely at the feet
of the Imam what were we supposed to do
just lay down and take it say nothing is
that the
answer I traffic only in the fact
I'd like you to address his other
question but I think that's a very
important Point mutual respect is a
two-way street it's a two-way street it
has to go both
ways when it comes to the
particulars uh I think that it's the
record is clear you know if there are
these questions about the Imam and his
uh activities and his uh inconsistent
statements and so on then uh who's being
disrespectful
is it he or is it I is it we who are
calling attention to it I don't think
that it's in the least unreasonable or
disrespectful to want to get answers and
clarity about what his intentions really
are and what he's up to as far as the
larger question that you asked about
Islam uh that's a matter of record and
anybody can read the Quran anybody can
study the Sharia Islamic law you can
look at the states where uh Sharia is
been has been fully implemented uh where
that's what they say that they're doing
where Saudi Arabia says there's no law
in Saudi Arabia except what is Islamic
law and the Islamic Republic of Iran as
well as Sudan and uh Somalia to a lesser
degree in various areas and if you look
at them there are various consistencies
there are various commonalities in the
uh laws that they Implement and if you
look into the uh various schools of
Islamic jurist Prudence the Sunni
schools the Shafi Maliki hanafi and
hanali schools and the Shiite Jafari
school if you look into the contents of
their teaching you will find a great
commonality really 75 or 80% of the laws
are generally the same among the schools
of jurist prudence and they're the same
kinds of laws that are implemented in
Saudi Arabia and Iran and they do not uh
Accord with universally AC otherwise
universally accepted Notions of human
rights to the slightest degree uh the
the uh execution the stoning there are
eight last I heard I'm not sure this is
an up-to-date count it's about a year
old but there were eight women uh on
death row in Iran awaiting stoning to
death for adultery there were uh in
Pakistan there was a study done by
actually an Islamic Reform Group sisters
in Islam that found that up to 70% of
the women who were in prison in Pakistan
also an Islamic Republic although not
fully Sharia compliant were there
because they were victims of
rape and under the HUD laws under the
the the the ways in which crimes of Zena
of sexual immorality are understood that
made them
guilty now these things are not
originated by me these things are
matters of record they're unpleasant yes
I think they should be opposed
strenuously yes but I think they should
be opposed strenuously because it's a
matter of love for human beings these
things are not good for
anybody Muslim non-muslim zoroastrian
whatever you want now when you say uh
there's some sort of of an implied
comparison with Christianity actually
I've made that comparison explicit I
wrote a book with the subtitle why
Christianity is and Islam is isn't in
question of is it a religion of peace
all religions don't teach the same
things but that is not the same kind of
question
as what we're talking about in terms of
behavior evil is not the property of any
individual group any particular
group evil is universally distributed
evil is within every human heart along
with the capacity to overcome it the
choice is yours in all the choices of
your life whether you're going to be
good and evil but every group every
religion every political system
everything you can name you can find
somebody who's done evil in its
name but this doesn't really address the
question of what we are to do about
Islamic violence today there's several
reasons for that one is there are an
armed groups of Jews or armed groups of
Christians killing people and
terrorizing people and justifying it
according to Jewish texts and teachings
or Christian texts and teachings in the
world today I'm talking today
historically you can find examples
certainly but there are also reasons why
you find them at various points in
history and then they recede at other
points in history in Islam the people
who are committing the acts of violence
make their appeal to Peaceful Muslims
precisely by selling themselves as being
the exponents of pure and true Islam
based on texts that are in the Quran and
in the example of Muhammad in the Sunnah
that have no parallel in Judaism or
Christianity texts like where Muhammad
says I've been commanded to fight
against people until they confess that
there's no God but Allah and I am his
Prophet or texts like the the three
Thrice repeated in the Quran slay the
infidels wherever you find them slay the
pagans wherever you find them that's a
chapter 28 chapter 2: 191 4:89 and
chapter 9:5 and the uh various other
Hadith where Muhammad prescribes
conversion or subjugation or War I
thought that was kind of absurd that
people act like that's an egregious
statement of mine because if it is they
have to condemn Muhammad too he said it
I just quoted
him my name is Steve RoR I live in
Philadelphia I have a two-part question
for Miss Geller first off
just for clarification you understand or
you agree with the statement that they
have the right to build the M the First
Amendment right protects them property
rights the zoning laws are being abided
by you absolutely so then my second part
of the question is how close is too
close or how far is far enough two
blocks is two closes it got to be four
blocks not Lower Manhattan not Manhattan
where do you where do you find the line
where to say it's not disrespectful to
the memory that folks who were killed on
911 not there that but that's but then
where anywhere any anywhere else
anywhere else not in a building that was
destroyed on the largest Islamic attack
on American soil that slaughtered
3,000 Americans who were going to work
having their lunch buying newspapers
left their house left their husbands
left their wives left their mothers not
in a building that was destroyed in an
attack that sought to take down this
country sir so to take down this country
it hit the financial epicenter it hit
the Pol the political epicenter if it
weren't for the heroes on the plane it
would have been the capital of the White
House and it hit the Pentagon so I say
not there where is there then what
anywhere else three blocks away four
blocks away that's okay you got it can
you make that deal I I'll I'll back you
up all the way I make a deal obviously I
just I just want to that's my that's my
thinking that building was listen he
said even though it was scrubbed from
The New York Times website in the first
article that was written on the ground
zero Mega mask in December of 2009 Imam
rouf said New York City is the capital
of the world and that building is Iconic
of 9/11 and when when you said 77% of
Americans close to 70 I'm sorry okay
close to well I want to get the number
right what what's the number of people
in Manhattan against it people actually
I want to say something the majority of
people in Manhattan are against it but I
don't think that's really um indicative
of anything but but uh maybe you know
being demographic about it what I mean
by that is would you consider um Pearl
Harbor a Hawaiian
issue no that's why I don't think I mean
it's an interesting question and the
majority of New Yorkers are against it
but I yes it's true it's it's not as
large as 60% or 70% I agree but the
majority of New Yorkers are against it
but I think it's it's an irrelevant
question this was an an attack on
America it was not an attack on on on
you know uh K Fitzgerald I guess we just
fundamentally disagree
on you know the right to baild something
there it's not the people from Al-Qaeda
it's not the criminals that perpetrated
a crime on 911 it's a different group
and I think there a very broad Rush yes
the question is uh it's a different
group but how exactly do their belief
systems differ uh it's never been
established that the Imam rouf rejects
the Islam of Osama bin Laden in any
particular accept tactically but there's
plenty of ways to get there if you're
going to the same goal and if you have
the same goal but you want to get there
by a different Road I'm sorry that's not
that's a distinction without a
difference and if the Imam raou is in
favor of Islamic law of sharia in its
most Draconian forms then and as seems
to be abundantly established from his
advocacy for this Sharia compliance
index which has States like Saud Arabia
and Iran at the top as a positive good
and then when he is calling for Sharia
in the United States then look the goal
of al-Qaeda is to impose Sharia over the
West so the Imam rou wants to do it by
going on television and making you all
think that you're standing for the good
when you're defending him and Osama Bin
Laden does it by flying planes into
buildings but they're both working for
the same thing
[Applause]
um I I appreciate you uh conceding at
the at the get-go that it isn't an issue
of constitutional right or uh I didn't
concede it I never thought it was okay
well you you prefacing your statement
yeah and and the argument you you
initially offered was um one of
compassion for the families who who died
in the towers um which is why the
proximity Is is so important to you know
two blocks is not is is not okay three
blocks is um it's not two blocks it is
Ground Zero do you think that the
terrorists knew the Muslim terrorists
when they were flying the planes into
buildings do you think they knew that
the planes were going to go down
invertedly the buildings were going to
go down invertedly and not destroy Lower
Manhattan H how could they know that
that building was part of the attack I
it needs to be clarified that 600 ft is
is is dishonest um so so three blocks is
not okay that wasn't my question but um
I I think it I would like to Echo his
question and say so three blocks is not
okay if not then then how far are you
are you willfully missing the point are
you are you intentionally missing the
point consistently been saying that this
building is part of the attack site if
you move the thing away from the attack
site then that's okay but this building
is part of the attack site we're not
saying two blocks is no good but three
blocks is okay that's the that's the
point here that it's part of the attack
site that's why that building is
important to rou he himself said it and
so did Daisy Khan that so I guess my
question Divine it was a Divine hand
that brought that building to
them so that's the Washington Post the
video is on my site so uh so the the
initial argument you proposed against
the mosque was uh one of comp out of
compassion for the families who were
killed uh in the building America this
is what you said um of the families of
the people who were killed they they and
America we're all 911 families every
single one of us in this room is a 9/11
family they just took the hit for
us so I guess my my question is um by
opposing the mosque are you not in part
uh being not compassionate to the the
Muslim individuals and their families
who were killed who were worked in the
towers cuz after all there was a mosque
in the South Tower so are you not uh not
being compassionate to those families uh
so you're saying it's only a oneway stre
Street are you saying are you saying
it's only oneway Street you say yeah are
you saying it's yeah that's what you're
saying that's what you're saying
yes you know it's interesting to note
that uh there were about 3,000 people
who were killed in the Twin Towers and
uh if you look at the actual
lists there are about 28 or 30 who uh
seem to be have have Muslim names you
know names like Muhammad or Abdullah or
various others and now this has been
wildly inflated as part of the
propaganda to sell this mosque to the
American people uh such that uh the the
Council on American Islamic relations
the Hamas linked Muslim Brotherhood
front has been uh saying 300 people uh
300 Muslims uh which is sort of
preposterous to start with to think that
a tenth of the people who are working in
the World Trade Center were Muslim it
just strains credulity and now I saw on
your flyer the defamatory flyer that was
being handed out 400 and pretty soon
it's going to be uh 2,000 2500 everybody
in there was Muslim the fact is look
there were a lot of non-muslims who were
killed on on 911 let's not forget that
either and so if you're going to build a
monument to them if you're going to do
it out of compassion then build a church
a synagogue a Hindu temple I'm sure
there were Hindus killed on in the in
the towers on 9/11 and and a mosque and
have them all together the problem here
is not about sensitivity or religious
freedom uh they're already praying and
the Burlington Coat Factory but the
Burlington Coat Factory is not a
16-story Triumph uh Monument of
Triumph and uh the to to act as if it
would be compassionate to this tiny
minority of victims of these attacks
that we have to put this Victory mosque
here this is just ridiculous uh then we
should just tally up the religious uh
affiliations of the various victims and
build buildings accordingly all ringing
Around the World Trade Center it's
absurd
[Applause]
oh